[Music]
on this saturday night trouble at the
top of canada's most high-profile
indigenous organization national chief
of the assembly of first nations
suspended over allegations of bullying
why the first woman to hold the rule
says she's the victim of a smear
campaign
unpacking airport chaos and
cancellations as coveted restrictions
lift and we're doing everything we can
to ease those bottlenecks the
transportation minister's plan to make
travel enjoyable again people are often
surprised that you know that that guy
was scared to leave his house focusing
on men's mental health this father's day
the hgtv star smashing the tough guy
stereotype and speaking about his own
journey and a cyclist his cello and a
ride through the former roman empire
[Music]
the british man creating his own sweet
soundtrack on the bike ride of a
lifetime global national with bara
nasser
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us tonight we begin with a growing
leadership crisis in canada's largest
and highest profile indigenous group the
board of directors for the assembly of
first nations says they've now suspended
national chief roseanne archibald over
complaints about bullying behavior but
as mike delay reports archibald says
she's being targeted by a smear campaign
and she's pledging not to step down from
the job she was just elected to a year
ago
the beginning of the summer solstice is
a traditional time for many indigenous
groups to celebrate their culture
through song and dance not the political
drama that has consumed the assembly of
first nations politics is
a place where
this doesn't belong afn national chief
roseanne archibald the first woman to
lead the afn has long fought to make the
organization more inclusive and
transparent on thursday archibald
tweeted she was the victim of a smear
campaign while calling for a forensic
audit and independent inquiry into the
conduct of the afn over the last eight
years without giving details the afn
executive committee revealed it would be
looking into complaints that had been
made against archibald archibald
responded by saying she would shine a
light on corruption and collusion within
the afn
that ultimately led to her suspension
for unfounded and unsubstantiated public
attacks on the integrity of the afn
russell diabolo who worked under two
national chiefs in the 1980s and 90s
says it appears to him that elements
within the afn were uncomfortable with
her allegations
that's clear
so what is it that they're afraid of
what is it the executive committee and
this um
chief executive officer afraid of in
terms of an audit
or an investigation into afn's uh where
did that money go and how was it used
archibald says she's not backing down
but where she goes from here is unclear
in addition to her suspension the afn
executive has banned her from attending
its annual general assembly in july
which diablo believes is an overreach
but to say she can't she suspended uh
and she can't go to the national uh
assembly
i think that's way beyond the scope of
their authority and i think there will
be consequences that that meeting in
vancouver mark my worst
it's going to be very hot and heavy but
will it provide the clarity the afn so
desperately needs
mike drewlay global news toronto
when russia invaded ukraine thousands of
volunteers from around the world
including right here in canada headed to
the region to take up arms for ukrainian
independence
now it's believed some 2 000 of those
international volunteers have been
killed in the fighting an unknown number
of others have been captured and as sean
o'shea reports from keeve they are
facing uncertain fate
with their hands bound the men were
marched down a hallway two americans now
in the clutches of russian soldiers who
control part of eastern ukraine
thirty-nine-year-old alexander drewkey a
retired army sergeant and 27 year old
andy hun a retired marine i mean they
don't look bad they look good they don't
look injured so
i think that's actually quite promising
if it turns out to be real the two men
from alabama went missing june 9.
in the russian video drookie apparently
talks about their military assignment
with some help from an interrogator of
task force baguettes
yes
they were attached to the ukrainian army
they were a recon unit prisoners can
often be forced to give information or
make false statements in videos like
these han is heard describing why he
signed up was back in america
before i left
i was
i was watching at the time a lot of
propaganda from the western side another
american fighter is also missing i have
been briefed we don't know where they
are u.s president joe biden told
reporters americans should not be
volunteering to help ukraine but i want
to reiterate
americans should not be going to ukraine
now say it again americans should not be
going to ukraine now two britons and a
moroccan have received death sentences
after pleading guilty to charges they
fought against russia in eastern ukraine
the european court of human rights has
told the russian government the
sentences should not be carried out
russian president vladimir putin didn't
mention the americans arrest during a
speech at the saint petersburg economic
forum
but russia's foreign ministry
spokesperson
americans
said everything needed to solve the
issue with the u.s government is in
place there are thousands of volunteer
foreign fighters here in ukraine from
various countries including canada
they'd also be in a vulnerable position
if captured our government has said it's
an individual decision on whether to
come here and fight farah
shawn o'shea reporting for us from keeve
thank you for your coverage sean
traveling through an airport these days
is not for the faint of heart with
somewhere around the corner and the
removal of more public health
restrictions many canadians are now
itching to get away and that's leading
to long lines at airports and passport
offices now the government is being
urged to fix the problem our ottawa
bureau chief mercedes stevenson spoke
with canada's transportation minister
about these ongoing issues mercedes
faro with the peak summer travel season
starting next week the federal
government has been under fire for a
slow response to covid chaos at canadian
airports and under pressure to make
changes fast to get travel back on track
in a bid to turn things around the
government suspended domestic vaccine
mandates to board planes and trains and
the mandate for outbound international
flights is heading for the departure
gate too but a number of mandates will
remain including the controversial
arrive can app used to document
vaccination for incoming travelers to
canada it has been criticized as
confusing time consuming and forcing
border guards to act as i.t support
border city mayors and business groups
are calling for the removal of the app
but this week on the west block
transport minister omar al-gabra says no
dice on tossing the app defending it as
a valuable tool to verify vaccination
status he says the government will work
to improve the troubled tech
we are working with public health
agency we are working with cbsa we're
working with airports and with travelers
and border communities to ensure how we
can improve
compliance
of our right can today we have over 90
percent
compliance rate the vaccine mandate for
inbound travelers to canada will stay in
place over 100 other countries have
removed it but keeping the requirement
keeps canada in step with the united
states minister algabra also defended
the government's slow response to long
lines at the airport promising more
staff and saying government projections
for return to travel were wrong a
different tone than the government
initially took when they blamed
out-of-practice travelers one coveted
change that is here to stay though
masking it will remain mandatory on
planes and trains in canada it is a
minor inconvenience that we're asking
travelers to endure
what that offers meaningful protections
to themselves and to the passengers
sitting next to them in a small enclosed
space i'm thinking of an immune
compromised person or an elderly person
who's traveling you can watch our full
interview with the minister of transport
tomorrow on the west block farah look
forward to it thank you mercedes
stephenson in ottawa the u.s is
teetering on a recession inflation is at
its highest level in four decades gas
prices are soaring and the stock market
is plummeting as jennifer johnson
reports while president joe biden says
the recession won't happen many
americans aren't so sure
from the grocery store to the gas pump
americans are paying record high prices
for just about everything they buy and
families are hurting my feeling when
pulling up to the gas station is
anxiety stress
inflation has hit its highest level in
41 years grocery prices are up 12
mortgage rates have hit a 13-year high
but it's skyrocketing gas prices that
are really hurting americans u.s
president joe biden is under increasing
pressure to act i'm using every lever
available to me to bring down prices for
the american people as the president
took a tumble off his bike in delaware
saturday morning a new usa today poll
shows his approval rating is tumbling
too just 39 percent of americans approve
of the job biden is doing
democrats now control both the house and
senate but that could change after
november's midterm elections republicans
are sending a clear message to voters
it's time for the biden and the
democrats to wake up and realize nothing
is free
somebody pays for it and that's you and
me as taxpayers the president blames big
oil companies for price gouging and a
global oil shortage due to the war in
ukraine
russia's war is driving up prices of gas
everybody knows that hurting people in
all our countries the white house also
says supply chain issues from the
pandemic are driving up prices on most
consumer goods
but americans are growing weary of
excuses the stock market is tanking down
17 percent so far this year crushing
retirement funds we've pumped a lot of
money into the system to try and bail
ourselves out of a complete economic
global shutdown due to the pandemic
right that is going to take a while to
unwind a different poll this week found
60 percent of global ceos believe the
u.s will fall into a recession at the
end of this month
we are in the midst of what leads to a
recession which is you're seeing the
consumer back off uh savings rates are
now well below pandemic levels we're
reaching back to 2008 2009 and savings
levels if a recession happens it will be
costly for consumers the president and
his party history shows americans vote
with their wallets which these days are
a lot leaner
jennifer johnson global news washington
coming up the crowded contest to replace
jason kenney the key to gaining an
advantage in the ucp leadership race
plus a major milestone for rock royalty
how sir paul mccartney spent his
birthday
in alberta the race to replace jason
kenney is taking shape with eight people
running to be leader but with a
provincial election a year away the
united conservative party has little
time to waste and as heather urex west
reports keeping this big tent party
together through a leadership contest is
not going to be easy
i've informed the president of the party
of my intention to step down as leader
of the united conservative party it's
been just a month since alberta's
premier stunned many with this
announcement and it's taken little time
for the race to replace him to hit full
speed leadership at the ucp is a great
prize
it's a party with
tens of thousands of members and expect
that number to be
probably hovering around 150 000 members
by the end of this race not to mention
whoever wins becomes the premier leading
a province suddenly awash in oil and gas
cash i'm running to become leader of the
united conservative party we must lead
with strength and humility together we
must revive revitalize and renew the
field of candidates has quickly grown
with eight so far in the hunt and a high
profile ninth waiting in the wings
federal conservative mp michelle rempel
garner shared her intentions wednesday
on twitter saying i can confirm that i
am giving a provincial leadership bid
serious consideration as such i will no
longer be participating in the federal
conservative leadership race so that i
can focus on how to best serve my
province it's difficult to imagine not
running after putting it out there like
that
so i think we can think of that almost
as a soft launch for her campaign the
united conservative party formed a
government with a decisive majority in
2019 but under jason kenney's leadership
the ucp has had a difficult time plagued
by infighting it's why this leadership
contest has come with some ground rules
on top of the
000 entry fee candidates must put up
another 25 000 refundable compliance
deposit to keep the hopefuls in line the
trick will be to not create divisions
that are wide enough that they cannot be
healed by the new leader when this thing
is ultimately
wraps
we are on the eve of the next election
the ucp leader will be elected in
october ahead of the provincial election
early next year heather urex west global
news calgary
ahead the mental health of the modern
dad the famous father of four opening up
about his anxiety ahead of father's day
this weekend offers a chance to
celebrate fathers and as you're
showering them with love there's a call
to check in on their mental health as
well many men simply won't talk about
how they're feeling afraid of being seen
as not strong enough
abigail biehmann takes us to an event
called father's day on the hill hoping
to address that stigma
you guys excited
i've never heard you all be excited for
school this father's day hgtv star and
data four brian baumler hopes other dads
will be open and honest with their kids
including about tough stuff i think if
i'd had someone to have those
conversations with you know
25 years ago that would have really
shortened the amount of time that i had
to deal with it dealing with crippling
anxiety that gripped bombler in his 20s
and 30s you'd get the tunnel vision and
the grade out and the the extreme high
heart rate and the sweat
and just the panic the sheer panic of
thinking i'm going to drop dead at any
moment tearing down tough guy
stereotypes bomler is opening up about
his mental health
including at this father's day on the
hill event backed by politicians of all
strikes people are often surprised that
you know that that guy was scared to
leave his house i'm like that guy almost
swallowed an entire bottle of ativan
just to stop
the panic in general stigma around
mental health has been lessening but the
head of the mental health commission of
canada says not so much for men still
less likely to talk about what they're
facing for fear of showing weakness
sadly three-quarters of canadians who
die by suicide are men they may be more
irritable they'd be
consuming more alcohol or cannabis
they may be broody they may be
putting themselves out they mean be not
seeing their friends that often those
are all signs that things could be
not well with them and you need to reach
out it was right after i had my my
second daughter and feeling incredibly
depressed not knowing who i could talk
to who to reach out to at least one in
10 men suffers from depression after the
birth of a child another issue less
talked about
conservative mp matt generous turned his
struggles into advocacy this event now
in its fifth year with a new foundation
called hi dad providing a resource for
men to go to to to really
have those have those things at their
fingertips to be able to to go and talk
to other men to know some of the
statistics and make those conversations
a bit more powerful and this father's
day any check-in conversation is a good
place to start
abigail beeman global news ottawa
how about skiing on father's day while
he warnings are in place across some
parts of the country it's still ski
season on vancouver island
mount washington resort reopening the
lifts this weekend for skiers and
snowboarders now normally by this time
of year the resort's mountain bike
trails are the main draw but with enough
snow the decision was made to restart
one chairlift and a handful of runs for
father's day
weather conditions like
heavy slushy and lots of fun the sun and
the fun and time with my daughter it's
father's day weekend we figured why not
come skiing and dress up at the same
time and make people smile
for both days this weekend the resort is
giving free passes to all dads
next the cycling cellist a british man's
unique musical ride through the heart of
the roman empire
what better way to celebrate your 80th
birthday than being serenaded by bruce
springsteen and 60 thousand fans
sir paul mccartney's actual birthday is
today but he's been receiving well
wishes for a while including the final
stop of his u.s tour on thursday night
on stage springsteen wished mccartney
another 80 years of glory days and it
appears mccartney is not slowing down
too much his concert set list included a
whopping 38 songs
also this next story is quite a feat a
british man is embarked on a 2500
kilometer bike ride from northern
england all the way to italy now every
good journey needs a soundtrack
so he's creating his own and it's not as
simple or as small as just packing a
smartphone the musician is also
entertaining an audience wherever he
goes crystal gomezing has his story
sunshine time and endless opportunities
[Music]
the summer of 2022 for kenneth wilson
is shaping up to be a grand adventure of
his own making
[Music]
there are kind of three elements to this
there's the bike there's the music and
there's a story
wilson's story began at the northwestern
frontier of the roman empire hadrian's
wall in england it will end at the
center of that ancient civilization
rome but like every good story the
in-between is where you find the magic
riding the bike is not very good for the
wrists because you get so much shape to
the handlebars and that makes playing
the cello very difficult
sustained strain took its toll on the
body and the bike and since this
adventure takes place on the road
the odd unexpected detour is to be
expected i ended up 50 miles from where
i should be two hours before i was
supposed to fall and
a man came out of his house and helped
me and said he'd give me a cup of tea if
i paid him a tune
[Music]
and he showed me the hairs on his arm
standing up on end in response to this
music
wilson performs because he knows the joy
music brings
[Music]
sometimes he plays to a crowd
other times he is alone and just feels
compelled like when he rode past a
commonwealth cemetery i just got my
cello out and i played these rows and
rows of white identical gravestones
just because it seemed
the right thing to do
his sidekick libre is always game but
why wilson took his cello grabbed a bike
and set off for italy he can't say if
there were a straightforward answer it
wouldn't be so interesting
at some point the highway cello will
become a book
for now it's life
and the journey continues
crystal commencing global news
london
and as for most things in life the
journey is the reward that's global
national for this saturday night i'm far
and officer thanks so much for spending
part of your evening with us tonight's
your canada is la county near saint
agath
quebec
we love seeing your canada keep sending
us your photos until tomorrow take care
of yourselves and each other good night
[Music]